Our second main principle for CS7637 was that learning in KBAI agents is
often incremental. This means that information or data or
experiences arrive one at a time. This is one of the key differences between
knowledge based AI, and other forms of AI, like machine learning. In those
forms a large amount of information is often given right at the beginning. Here,
our agents learn step by step, incrementally. We first encountered this with
learning by recording cases. Our agents learned each individual case one by one.
The experiences themselves were the increments in this learning strategy.
Case based reasoning also operated on individual cases, but
it organized them into much more complex knowledge structures.
Like tagging them in an array. Or organizing the my discrimination tree. But
the fundamental object of knowledge were still individual cases that arrived one
by one. We did a complex exercise where one by one we added these new cases into
our discrimination tree. Incremental concept learning was, as the title suggest,
incremental. Here were received positive and negative examples one at a time.
Based on the difference between our current concept, and our new example, and
whether or not the new example was a positive or negative example.
We would change our concept. This is always done example by example,
incrementally. Version spaces involved a very similar kind of knowledge.
Here experiences came one at a time, and we generalized a specific model and
specialized the general model to converge down to an understanding of
the concept. Finally, learning by correcting mistakes is also
deeply incremental. Here, the individual mistakes arrived incrementally, and
based on the individual mistakes, our agent modified it's
knowledge base to repair the cause of the previous mistake.
To take away here is that many of our methods in learning, reasoning and memory.
All involve dealing with information that comes incrementally, bit by bit,
instead of processing a large amount of data all at the same time.
One can also see this connects more closely to human experience,
where we're constantly experiencing the world experience by
experience instead of being given a lifetime of experiences all at once.